well your ability to avoid paying sales
tax by shopping online is up for debate
by the US Supreme Court as well and a
decision from the justices could affect
the price you pay by checking out over
the Internet of course Mount Garrett any
looks at that argument before the court
the days of paying less for shopping
online could be coming to an end
42 states are locked in a heated battle
with some of the Internet's biggest
retailers over the ability to charge
sales taxes a lot of online retailers
don't collect sales taxes which is in
part why items will often cost a bit
less than they do at a physical
brick-and-mortar store that might be
great for customers but for the states
that can add up to billions of dollars
in lost tax revenue South Dakota is
leading this charge asking the High
Court to overturn its long-standing
precedent out-of-state retailers get a
price advantage and alls we're asking
the Supreme Court is to make you the
loving the level playing field and we're
asking to treat everybody the same
during arguments today the justices
appeared reluctant to overturn their
prior rulings much of the discussion
revolved around the burden that small
online businesses and startups would
face if forced to collect sales taxes
attorneys for the online retailers argue
that burden would be significant given
that there are 12,000 tax jurisdictions
in the country each with their own rates
rules and holidays Chief Justice John
Roberts seemed to agree with that notion
saying it's not that e-commerce is
expanding the problem you have to
address is that the coverage in terms of
collecting the taxes is expanding as
well just as Neil Gorsuch took an
opposing view arguing the court
shouldn't be picking winners and losers
saying why should we favor this court
favor a particular business model that
relies not on brick-and-mortar but on
mail-order the states counter small
businesses can easily comply with the
various taxes by using accounting
software but outside the court several
independent online sellers disagree it's
arrogant to say how easy it is to comply
with online sales tax and then you want
me to do it in 46 states and with
thousands of jurisdictions and you think
you just flip a switch to do that good
luck because it doesn't happen that way
this argument comes amid president
Trump's feud with
the largest online retailer and while
Amazon is not a party in this case the
ruling could impact third-party sellers
on the site who don't collect sales
taxes the justices are expected to issue
a decision by the end of June Bret
Guerra thank you